well we do a lot of virtual things on
khan academy and we teach science and
the goal of the summer camp really is to
give the students a real physical
experience that really connects a lot of
the concepts that you might learn on
something like a khan academy video so
we do things like real engineering we
play we build lego robots that the
students actually write software for
that autonomously sumo wrestle we do
market simulations we perform experiment
experiments but this all involves indoor
and outdoor activities so we just do a
bunch of stuff that really connects a
lot of the abstract conceptual things
that you might learn on say a khan
academy video and then you bring it into
the classroom so in the market
simulation students learn about
probability they learn about game theory
they learn about trading in the robotics
they learn about engineering they learn
about math they do a lot of trigonometry
and geometry so we really try to make it
all very tangible for the students
so this is mental boot camp 2010
um it's a one week course held in
portola valley in the bay area for about
20 to 25 students ranging from sixth
grade to roughly ninth grade spend a
week exploring math and science and
technology in the real world what you're
seeing today is a big part of our course
which is the robotics portion and we're
using the lego mindstorm nxts and we've
given the kids a challenge for the week
to make a sumo wrestling robot and
they're designed to fight on these
wooden tables that you see
one-on-one
and the idea is to push your fellow
robot off the edge
so they're using a variety of tools
within the robots there are sensors to
detect when you've fallen off the edge
there are other things like the motors
to drive them around
and then they've got actuators to hammer
on each other and push each other off
so that's the main thrust of the week
we're spending
half of the time doing robotics and then
the other half we're doing board games
we're doing the math behind board games
probability and statistics
game theories the kids are also learning
about markets and for example trading
markets and how they work hi i'm rahul
and i'm lance and today and this week
we're building a lego nxt robot at um
for our project
uh right the goal is to push the
opponent's robot off the table before
your robot falls off we can do that by
making
um
the ultrasonic sensor to try and it goes
and tries to look for it yeah and
there's a light sensor to make sure it
doesn't fall off the table and also
here we have a motion
touch sensor which so that when it backs
up it doesn't fall off this table
because there's no because the uh
ultrasonic sensor is facing that way and
so is the light sensor that's why we've
stuck a touch sensor back here we also
have some wheels and these are our
motors
uh this
isn't working very well but it's a
whacker it just kind of whacks the your
opponent's robots
to
try and disassemble it or push it or
knock it off balance or something
and here we can try it in motion
but i'm just gonna run the program
i can't see it yeah
your robot still won